so what you're saying is the FBI owns
Bitcoin yes 100 so these are like right
out of the gate you guys knew this is
going to be a challenge the rise of
crypto is is the reason for ransomware
right around the start of Silk Road
someone had posted on a forum that said
they needed help running a
what's not Albrecht gmail.com so when
you walk out of the cafe you go left and
he's right there in the cross in the
crosswalk
you have the arrest warrant with you
it's in my pocket and you don't let him
go okay why all right guys bang bang
I've got Chris here with me uh you are
known as the guy who took down a bunch
of these bad people on the internet uh
some people think they're bad some
people think they're not it's all super
controversial uh you've had incredible
experiences both I think in kind of the
rise of your career but then also
blowback for a bunch of stuff that
happened uh I would love to First just
start with like what the [ __ ] is the
dark web right like all of these groups
all these things everyone hears about
the dark web on the internet what is the
dark web so people talk about the dark
web and the Deep Web okay the Deep Web
is pretty much anything that can be
reached by Google it's not indexable I
mean they there's always a picture of an
iceberg online and you know the internet
that Google Sees is that little tip of
the iceberg above the water and then the
Deep Web is but beneath that the the
stuff under the military history you
might not understand you go do the Deep
Web all the time if you go to your bank
account your bank accounts in the Deep
Web Google can't index your bank account
you don't want that you don't want them
to be well so that's in the deeper then
we have the dark web the dark web is for
me is where all the criminal activity
happens okay so you can have dot-coms
that are
bad bad places that's that's dark web
um but people traditionally talk about
like Tor or hidden services and that
sort of thing we're really the nefarious
stuffer is going on okay so we have like
what's called Google World then you have
the Deep Web that deep web that's just
somebody who set up a website who like
let's say the bank for example they put
up a firewall or something like that
that just prevents people from being
able to index it or access it yeah a
password a password protected site is
part of that you know so so Google can't
go through and and find the site and you
can't like search Anthony's bank account
like I said you can't get there you
can't Google doesn't find it okay so uh
it's clear to me how I get to my bank
account or somebody else gets to kind of
these Deep Web stuff the dark web uh I
was telling you earlier that I have a
friend who one day he's just randomly
it's always a friend everybody
pretty good uh and so I mean this kid
was like incredibly smart right he's
like playing around everything and like
when he was accessing tour for the first
first time I ever saw it I didn't know
if he was like performing and he was
doing a bunch of stuff to make it seem
cooler and better or if like it
literally was multiple steps to kind of
get in so like when you think about
people going to the dark web let's maybe
take it not from the criminal
organizations but like the guy who's
going to go and order weed or whatever
off of uh off the dark web or whatever
they're gonna order how are they usually
accessing it is it through a tour or is
it some other service or are they using
like a special computer like how are
people doing this so I don't want to
make a road map for kids out there to
buy buy weed and I'm not I'm not doing
that
um but to answer your question in the
hypothetical if you're 18 if you're 18
or younger please stop listening
um so it's specialized software to get
on towards the Tour bundle um you
download the browser
um and it just it's a it's a way of your
computer talking to the network okay um
it's a special you know explain that
more because I think most people are
like okay there's Tor like I've heard of
it whatever but like what exactly is it
doing to actually be able to access a a
part of the internet which Google's not
touching but also like criminals seem to
really want to use this sure so Tor
operates in in two different ways so
it's a collection of computers around
the world normal computers that you and
I would know about they're just running
running this specialized software and
there's two different things you can do
on it there's hidden Services which are
called dot onions that's just a website
on on tour within that specialized
network but then also you can use it to
access the the real internet so let's
say you want to go to a site and you
didn't want the government to know you
were going there you didn't want your
ISP to know you were going there you'd
use Tor and you'd go through their
Network and you'd come out on the other
end maybe you had an IP address that
um belonged to Germany an IP address is
just just like a phone number for a
computer
um you go through the tour Network and
you can go to Facebook or you can go
anywhere you want and they can't really
track you the way Tor works is it
encrypts your traffic
um so let's say I want to talk to three
I want to talk three places away I take
my internet traffic and use the Tour
bundle and it takes that information and
wraps it it puts a wrapper around it of
encryption and then sends it to the next
node or a tour relay that takes that
information and wraps it with more
encryption and sends it to the next
relay well that next relay doesn't know
me it only knows that that's that second
relay and I don't know that other relay
and it goes through these those are
called Hops and then the information
gets the information I'm looking for on
a service and it sends it back to me oh
I only know the one befriending me and
the relays only know what's in front of
them and behind them so you can't really
trace the traffic so really it's a
peer-to-peer network and on that
peer-to-peer network uh you know
basically the nodes that you're
connected to but you don't know kind of
the greater network of of who's sending
through the nodes you're connected to
and so in some way uh tour is very
similar to bitcoin there's some
differences but there's some
similarities as well unlike this
peer-to-peer Network yeah yeah and you
and they publish which you know what the
IP address is in there uh but you don't
know which ones you're connecting to at
the time so
um you know it's kind of open like
Bitcoin where you can kind of see what
the network what computers are made of
the network but you wouldn't know which
one of those is a certain Onion Browser
or anything like that or onion onion
service so when people access the dark
web obviously I'm somewhat joking that
like only criminals use it uh there are
people who would use it for positive
purposes maybe let's start there just
like as you all set like the law
enforcement seat like what are reasons
why somebody would use it for a a
positive way or like not for criminal
activity sure well it was invented by
the US Navy
um so the US government you know still
funds quite a bit of it
um it was made for like spies in other
countries to talk to other spies and
that Network couldn't you couldn't see
what they're saying and you didn't know
where they were to talk back and forth
um and so there are people that use it
inside countries that maybe their
government controls what they can look
at and what they can say and talk about
so they use it that way um there's
people in the United States that use it
for privacy I mean it certainly is a you
know if like I said your ISP knows what
traffic you're going to and can look at
it but if you're using Tor all they know
is you're using Tor that's it and when
you look at that like privacy enhancing
technology obviously has become much
more the Forefront there's all kinds of
things whether it's her on speech around
money uh many topics we'll talk about
today
um how do you think about like privacy
enhancing Technologies being used by
good people and people who are are
nefarious like like it's almost like
it's a tool right it's kind of like if I
give you a shovel well if you kill
somebody then you use the shovel to bury
it like is the shovel now bad like not
really it's like you're the bad person
uh but also you can use it to dig and
build a big building and like now you're
amazing person and you make much money
so like how do you think about privacy
enhancing technology as just one tool
that many of these battle organizations
but also good people are using
so I mean people always talk about that
and they talk about like they've
recently had a conversation about like
tornado cash and how you know this
Anonymous payment system is used and I
can come up with an example of why it's
really really bad I mean the worst
example is you know when I was in the
FBI I worked uh child exploitation cases
where parents were renting their
children out
um you're [ __ ] kidding me no it's
real it's really how and this was years
ago I mean you could wrench a child out
for a certain amount of money and now if
you had an anonymous payment system it's
really difficult for me to track you
down uh put on top of that Anonymous you
know computer Communications so it's
going to be almost impossible so I can
pull your heartstring I know you're a
parent I know you you know that's gonna
get you you're gonna be like well [ __ ]
this I'm not gonna use this it's not
worth it it's not worth privacy but I
don't I don't know if I would just go
jump to like uh we shouldn't have it as
much as it it becomes this like cat and
mouse game and I've I've probably
thought about it more than most people
right in terms of uh um there are
certain Technologies uh Bitcoin but
there's also many other technologies
that that people are using today to do
things that may not have been possible
previous peer-to-peer networks in
general obviously afford that
opportunity but what's interesting to me
about them is uh if we go back and look
at almost every technology in history
that ended up being very valuable uh the
criminals used it first like they were
using cell phones and beepers and like
all this crazy [ __ ] that like now we
don't associate uh beeper like well it's
just Antiquated but like when it became
the business tool it wasn't like oh
that's the drug dealer tool right but
like there's almost this weird mechanism
where like the bad people are trying to
get away from guys like you right and so
like they're trying to evade law
enforcement they're trying to evade uh
kind of the watchful eye their
surveillance all the stuff and so they
find these Technologies first but we
don't want them to use it for the bad
stuff like we wanted to get me some
adoption and be used for good stuff so
it's like almost like it's a sign that
the technology is valuable if the bad
people use it first but then you have to
transition to where the majority of
people are actually good actors not the
not the nefarious people I don't know
it's weird yeah I know I agree with you
I'm torn I'm a technologist I want to
see things move forward I like new
technology just coming out there but you
know criminals are opportunistic they're
like water they're going to find the
cracks in the system and they're going
to exploit them and that's sort of
what's happening and and law enforcement
is reactionary we want to be reactionary
we don't really want them to be very
proactive and stop and [ __ ] technology
that's the worst thing that could happen
yeah um we you know we want to move
forward with it so I feel you and I use
that example of the child expectation
just to pull [ __ ] out on that yeah
but exactly do you give up privacy
because of that
um because we have the risk of this one
thing do we give up our our privacy and
do we give up you know moving technology
forward I personally don't think so and
I'm a father of two yeah and I you know
I've seen the images I've seen what's
going on it's it's horrible
um you know we need to put more effort
into stopping those people but not
necessarily stopping that use of
Technology how do you guys normally
catch those types of people like we're
gonna talk about a bunch of different
cases today but like take for example uh
uh the child Predators things like that
uh is it like high-tech Solutions or is
it like no these people are just [ __ ]
dumb and like they literally like leave
a receipt somewhere or you know like
what I would think of as like kind of
quote-unquote police work yeah that's
the low-hanging fruit and those people
are are you know they're caught and you
know prosecuted
um but yeah the high-tech stuff is
really kind of where it has to go
because we want to you know and you want
to do a name and shame you want to
address as many people as you can and
you want to get it out there in the news
and be like if you're doing this stupid
[ __ ] we're gonna get you
um you know we're not gonna stop until
we've got every last one of you
um it's sort of a whack-a-mole but the
harder we're in the more moles we can
whack uh the better for it so you join
the FBI yup you want to do it your whole
life or what like why why join the FBI
um so I grew up uh the chief of police
lived across the street from me and I
was going to go to school for pre-med
um but he would come home and the badge
of the gun and all that and I was just
really interested in it and then about
my junior year of college I decided that
I didn't really like people uh okay so I
wasn't you know medical school maybe
wasn't for me um I liked the I and I
found out what I liked about I like the
investigating you know oh your your nose
is running why is it running let's try
to see what's going on on so the
investigative side of me was kind of
drawn towards that so
um pre-med all through college uh junior
year I decided I was going to switch it
up and I said uh I was I joined the
local police department as a campus
Cadet where I went to college at James
Madison University and it's like a
student-run organization and we had a
lot of interaction with cops uh and
there's a sergeant there named Sid
Hartman
um and he said man computers are the way
of the future
um so the next day I went up to the
computer science department and said
what I got to do to double major
um and the guy said get him get a
master's degree so I stuck around
finished my pre-med got a master's
degree in career science and I knew I
was going to use that in law enforcement
so yeah all because Sid Arden told me uh
that there's the wave of the future and
this was
97 98 yeah it could be a pretty good
investor yeah yeah he was ahead of time
um all right so uh you guys a computer
science degree how do you get to the FBI
um so I while I was in computer science
uh getting my degree I was a local cop
uh got kind of learned that that way and
work for two different police
departments was down there it's in
Virginia getting my degree and then I
put in my application and you know uh
they brought me on board I did computer
forensics for the first four years so
kind of Quantico a flight team out of
the Quantico so most people uh think of
the FBI they're like oh the special
agents they show up they got the
windbreakers on they're like doing the
whole gig right uh computer forensics is
similar to that different than that like
what are the differences I guess between
like the computer forensics team and
like maybe what people would think of as
like what they see the FBI in the movies
sure so I was an headquarters team and
we went and supported all the different
cases around the world so we would do a
medical fraud case in Kansas City
um then we'd fly over overseas and do a
cell phone of a terrorists going through
the through Heathrow or something like
that like it was a wide variety of like
anything involving computer any sort of
crime uh we sort of had our fingers in
into evolved in uh in doing it so it
really kind of it taught me how to
investigate cyber crime by looking at
all these different devices and
different ways of looking at things so
like there's a terrorist going through
the airport somebody name's on a list or
something they stop home uh he's got a
computer or a phone or whatever with
them they just hold them there and they
call you guys up you fly over there and
like you like investigate the computer
like how does that work it's a little
bit more secretive than that we might
know they're coming in or going in or
they don't know they're on some sort of
a list and they might get pulled over
into secondary search and their devices
are separated from them for a few
moments uh that sort of thing got it uh
is that common
uh the government's very good about that
sort of thing yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
guess that's like part of that uh what
are you looking for when you're doing
that right so like let's say for example
uh use the terrorists going through an
airport they don't know they're on a
list they get according to secondary
search they're separated from their
phone you're doing something whatever
you tell me what you guys were doing in
you know six seven years ago or not
um but what are you looking for is it
like names and numbers is it like
criminal activity what is it I'll be
honest with you and I'll tell you
exactly what I look for okay Girls Gone
Wild videos what I've never looked into
a terrorist computer that didn't have a
Girls Gone Wild video now I mean I I I'm
not joking
uh I didn't look at Bin Laden yeah I did
physically see Bin Laden's computers oh
really they were sitting in the office
when I walked by one time I was like oh
[ __ ] there's a palette of Bin lines
computers yeah I thought that was pretty
interesting I'm pretty sure there's a
book called Bin Laden papers uh or yeah
it's called Bin Laden papers uh and uh
the author went through and translated
all papers all the stuff and everything
and talks about all the other stuff that
was found and uh if I remember correctly
the seals who stayed for the extra like
18 minutes or whatever and they grabbed
all the uh materials and intelligence
and stuff uh there's VHS tapes and all
this [ __ ] but like there's porn too
wow yeah I've heard that it was in a
documentary but um but yeah I mean for
some reason always you know they hate
the Western world but they love the
girls gone wild stuff human nature takes
over and then it's just intelligence uh
it really is you grab as much as you can
and it gets digested and crossed uh
checked with everybody else's uh data
and uh you know kind of build a picture
from there yeah and so like a lot of
times is it fair to say that like you
may not even actually know what you're
looking for as much as you're like we
know that we believe this person is
involved in Acts but like we're trying
to grab as much information as we can
and then we like put it together in this
puzzle and like the puzzle will become
clearer as we get more information yeah
yeah we were just we're grabbing as much
data as we possibly can in the analysts
digest it and kind of put the bubbles
together and the lines connecting those
bubbles do the people or did the people
ever understand or realize that this had
happened or they just like I just got
secondary search and like they move on I
think most didn't uh and I think most
probably brought some sort of uh dummy
phone or you know they would bring a
device that didn't they knew was clean
if they especially if they knew they're
on some sort of list I mean we did the
same when we went to foreign countries
we would bring computers that we
intentionally left in hotel rooms
um you know just to see what happens
it's a cat and mouse game but it's fun
so all right so if that happens like you
you go to a foreign country you leave
the computer there I'm assuming there's
things on the computer that you want
them to discover sure yeah is this um
when I was in Iraq one of the things
that they would do is they would find
these weapons Depots and they would
replace uh some of the explosives with
inert explosives and then they would
eventually find on the battlefield
somewhere and unfortunately usually was
next to real live IEDs but then they
would be like okay cool we left this
here now it's here like we can start to
map this network I'm assuming similar
type of activity similar stuff yeah or
stuff that would Beacon home or even
talk home or is you know yeah anything
like that and there's um and for those
that don't know uh this is like a very
very well understood well-documented
strategy of law enforcement intelligence
organizations Etc I think you can go way
back uh even further in Vietnam but in
Vietnam there's something called
operation Rising Sun and what they would
do is they would uh if I remember
correctly they would find the weapons
Depots and there would be bullets in
there and then obviously they're going
to blow up all the bullets or like take
them like you can't really do much so
they would replace some of the bullets
with explosive bullets wow and so uh the
Viet Cong would be in the battlefield
and they'd be shooting and also I'm like
your buddy's gun blows up like you're
like not so excited about shooting your
gun now right and so like there are all
these kind of like psychological games
that get played as well
um when you're doing that stuff is that
like more offensive than defensive
because I think of a lot of law
enforcement as like something happens
we're reacting we're like almost playing
defense is to like leave a computer
somewhere is that more offensive type
stuff uh yeah Anderson's gain a little
intelligence you know to see what
happens to the computer and that sort of
thing and you know that story that
wasn't the world I was in but you know
if I was in a country and I was asked to
do something I would you know simple do
it you know and then the intelligence
would be gathered after yeah um you know
I that wasn't my game was more evidence
collection and then uh once I you know
law enforcement the reactionary stuff
yeah so when do you first hear about
Bitcoin
Bitcoin was brought to me by uh a guy
named Elon young he was an agent on my
squad so in the government there's a
thing called user lose
um so uh if you don't you get vacation
time if you don't use it you lose it uh
and so from again not a road map of when
to commit crime from Thanksgiving to New
Year's all the senior agents are gone
um so it's time to catch up on your
paperwork do whatever you got to do
um and so Christmas time of I guess it
was
2010 either one came into the squad and
said hey we got this thing
um it's me him and a guy named Tom
Kiernan
um who you know he's the computer
scientist on the squad we're sitting
around and he's like explaining to us
what this is and so we set up a computer
in the back we started mining I said
let's let's learn about it that's what's
going on so okay this is fascinating to
me because 2010 Christmas 2010 is what
two years give or take since the launch
January 3rd 2009. uh at this point uh I
believe it is now listed on exchanges uh
there is a pro there is like a price to
it uh but it's still very few people in
the world know what it is like it's
basically the white papers like the only
marketing thing that's out there do we
know how he found out about it I don't I
mean I mean very close contact with it
on uh so I could find out but I don't
remember he just came in he was always
ahead of this sort of thing like he was
just kind of reading up on things and
he'd be on forums and all that sort of
anything new technology little one was
the guy to go to so it's interesting
because it a lot of Technologies come
top down like they go you know Nation
State Corporations then the individual
you can think of the internet right as
you mentioned and even dark web whatever
this was so Bottoms Up right and so like
literally the place to learn about it
was not like go look at the government
budget what they're investing in it was
like go to the Forum that like nobody
knows about yeah and so it as you guys
get there uh and you start to learn
about it you're like let's go start
mining did you do this every time you
guys heard about new technologies like
oh let's go try it or like what what
made you want to go mine versus do
something else well we we had one we had
nothing else to do because no one was
around the boss wasn't around anything
like that
um it was like I said I'm a technologist
I'm always interested in these new
things so yeah we were involved in in
any sort of thing like that I mean if we
weren't having a LAN party in the back
you know shooting each other
um you know we were you know trying
these new things that out there and you
know we like to stay on top of it and
knowledge a little about it because you
know it would come up and you don't want
to look like you know there's a lot of
around probably a little after that
there was a lot of senior agents that
were kind of coming on and like oh I'm
gonna join cyber the last three years so
I can get a job
um and that you know so when they left
they would then get a job because they
could see they were in the Cyber unit
yeah you know because it's kind of funny
when you're in uh we're in the academy
and I know I'm jumping back and forth
um when you're in the academy kind of
like you're put into your Specialties
you know you got your criminal guys your
intelligence guys and your
counterterrorism guys you know those are
like it's what you want to do the kind
of channels and you got cyber dorks uh
my class there was like six of us and
you know they kind of made fun of us
they're the computer guys and all that
and that sort of thing I was like you
know the computer guys are going to have
a job skill at one point you might want
to think about and so it took the agents
a little waste their career to realize
like oh [ __ ] there's no counterterrorism
after I get out of the bureau what am I
going to do uh I'm going to join a
computer Squad and kind of get that what
is the culture inside the FBI and you
left 2014 or so
um like I think of law enforcement the
same I would think of the military the
same I would think of like a sports
locker room or whatever there's like a
lot of kind of like [ __ ] talking each
other but it's something like a friendly
way and and it's um uh got a very
specific type of culture that like
usually wouldn't be allowed in like a
normal company but it's this like
different type of organization is that
similar to how the FBI it was my
experience I mean it's a Brotherhood I
mean I was in the New York office for
the last six years of my career and you
know you're put on a specialized Squad
so our whole Squad is computers where I
had classmates you know their first day
out of the academy they're on a SWAT
team you know and that's what they did
because you know the senior guys didn't
want to do it so it really is what field
office you go to New York's the biggest
field office and you know the there's a
there's called Ras uh residence he's a
smaller satellite office the office the
Brooklyn ra would be the fifth largest
FBI office uh and that's just a
satellite office off in New York so
that's just to give the sense of how big
the New York office is yeah
um I mean it's kind of crazy right like
do we know how many agents work at the
FBI now
when I I want to say like 14 000
somewhere around there maybe between
like 11 5 and 14 or 15 000.
um just to put that you know NYPD has
over 40 000 cops and that's just one
city law enforcement it's interesting
because you have like okay let's say
it's 14 15 000 FBI then you've got you
said 40 000 for uh NYPD then you've got
like just the IRS like new influx maybe
87 000. right like you started like put
these numbers in and in some ways 14 000
is a lot to some people but 14 000 is
also not a lot if you're like
essentially monitoring the globe yeah
and then we're spread across the globe
and there's FBI agents all over the all
over the world I mean there's what is
the FBI's Mission like is it more
domestic focused International it's
everything like how did you guys inside
of the organization think about like
we're here to do X so I was a criminal
investigator so mine was criminal cyber
my entire life and so I worked just on
that the house is split there's an
intelligence side you know
counterterrorism intelligence and
there's the criminal side
um
we know about those guys and we knew who
they were and all that but see them in
the hallway yeah we didn't really well
not really because they're in skips and
all that those guys those guys live in a
world where their cell phone has to go
into a box before they go to their desk
um so everyone was always like oh they
you know I'll hear from them eight hours
from now when they finally leave you
know or something like that so it was a
different world yeah um it's kind of
crazy
um all right so you guys start mining
Bitcoin uh are you mining a lot a little
like is it just like one computer are
you like oh [ __ ] let's become
billionaires no I mean no I mean I mean
we're talking about Pennies on the
dollar back then you know maybe you know
it was a dime maybe it was worth maybe I
don't even think it was that High
um I don't even know where those
Bitcoins are they're on some hard drive
sitting on a shelf somewhere uh it's
probably on the 22nd floor of the New
York office somewhere I'm sure so what
you're saying is the FBI owns Bitcoin
yes 100 there's Bitcoin sitting on a
hard drive somewhere unless unless
someone wiped it which I can't imagine
they would wipe that computer yeah I've
said this before uh there's somebody I
know who works at the DEA and uh he told
me that the first time he ever saw kind
of the intersection of uh Bitcoin and
law enforcement was they were mining but
uh the way he told the story is like
they had put in budget requests to go
try to purchase Bitcoin so they then
could try to use it in uh investigations
but everyone said what the [ __ ]
Bitcoin like this is crazy whatever so
then they just put in a budget requests
for computers and they're like yeah sure
you guys need computers whatever and
they were using that to mine and then
obviously it wasn't kyc like all this
stuff now I don't know how true it is or
not uh but it is fascinating where you
guys were like doing it from like an
intellectual exercise did that drive you
more and more to like start thinking
about crime in the Bitcoin world or like
at the time was there no even thought
process like people probably committed
crime it's just like literally this is a
computer science like interesting
exercise let's go learn about it no it
was an old [ __ ] moment yeah because
we're you know in cyber crime there's
two different ways of going at it
there's tracking the IP addresses and
there's tracking the money uh you know
PayPal stuff or anything online that was
kind of bank accounts and all that and
this was an oh [ __ ] we can't track this
this is going to be a problem
um it is like right out of the gate you
guys knew this is going to be a
challenge yeah I think sitting around
Tom ill one and I was sitting around we
was like you know this is this is going
to be an issue and then finally when the
New Year's came in we started talking to
the senior guys they were like yeah I
can see where this is going to be a
problem yeah okay so uh it's fascinating
that like right away you guys are like
oh [ __ ] right
um no we didn't see where it was going I
mean the rise of crypto is is the reason
for ransomware yeah I mean all that
stuff all this crazy online stuff is is
because of the rise of crypto okay so
we're gonna talk about that in a second
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
and eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eight sleep dot com slash
pump not only do I sleep on it every
night it literally changed my life and I
begged the founders to let me invest in
the company eightsleep.com go get
yourself an eight sleep pod and get a
better night of sleep uh when you start
out looking at okay this is going to be
a difficult for us whatever talk a
little bit about the relationship
between like these federal law
enforcement agencies and the payment
companies like is it uh okay we think
this person's a bad person let's go to
like a fisa court or something get an
order then they give us the information
like how does that relationship work uh
in like the most General sense I know
there's tons of outliers but like like
how I guess maybe how is it supposed to
work five is of course the other side of
the house we didn't do that criminal
side we're doing with the Grand Junction
what is the fisa court uh it's a court
of regular judges who do a cycle and
they hear the National Security cases
the stuff that can't be publicly made we
do grand jury subpoenas and search
warrants okay on our side of the house
and so it's like not National Security
things and these are like public hearing
like could somebody just like go to a
New York courthouse and like listen to
you say hey I need this person's payment
information nope that's a grand jury
it's secret information it falls under
6E
um so there's a secret grand jury and in
in some jurisdictions not in New York
and some jurisdictions the agent
actually goes before the grand jury 18
people and says I need this person's
this account's uh payment information or
uh think about a subpoena is like is
like a letter uh if I send you a letter
all a subpoena gets me is what's on the
outside of the envelope two from the
date it was sent and all that sort of
thing if I want to see inside you need a
search warrant it's the same thing with
payment information I get your name your
bank account number and stuff like that
but I wouldn't see your transactions I
need a search warrant for that
information okay uh so I'd go to sorry
finish I'd go to the grand jury and I'd
say I need this information they might
ask why and I tell them why and then I
would take that subpoena that they issue
it's their Authority and send it to the
payment people the information would
come back and then I'd have to tell them
what the answer was this is what I got
back from them got it okay uh when you
go before the secret grand jury or
Grandeur I guess
um do they ever say no uh sure sure but
more the cutoff line is this is my
experience in New York again it's more
different everywhere it's a different
everywhere all the trolls calm down
we're caveating everything go ahead
it's more the ausa you go to the ausa
and they go to the Grand they they send
some paperwork to the grand jury and the
paper that comes back no one actually
goes out in Oklahoma I know my boss was
out in Oklahoma City he'd actually have
to go okay I never had that experience
in New York you centered over the USA
and a few times even the ausa is like we
can't do that what the hell are you
asking for we had there was a hacking
group uh in 2000
11 2012 and there were kids that were
like doxing and um bomb threats and all
that sort of thing and we found out one
kid went to a high school in uh Richmond
Virginia how did you find that out
um stuff online we figure out who he was
you know Twitter posts and stuff like
that we kind of figure out we all we
knew his name was Mike and he went to a
high school and uh like I mean not to uh
uh water down the work that's going into
this but like there's a lot of people
who like meet a girl or a guy at a bar
and like go do cyber stalking like to
some degree like that's a little bit of
the work to at least kind of get the
ball rolling to try to understand like
who is this person where do they go to
school or whatever and then you like go
start doing like actual law enforcement
work we're really good at it if you want
a cyber soccer girlfriend we're we're
really good at it that scares the [ __ ]
out of me but okay well I mean don't
meet Chris at a bar no I'm married
though so thank god um I mean the good
thing about it is not going to change it
is uh you know that I used to have to
get a search warrant to look in your
house yeah now you just go look on your
Facebook your kid's Facebook page he's
got pictures all inside your house and I
can see exactly what's sitting around
and those sort of things so people kind
of gave up privacy it does and like
what's interesting about this
um is it's not lost to me right there's
a lot of people who I think are like
okay cool what these guys are all doing
is uh is important in stopping you know
there's national security stuff or crime
or like whatever there's a bunch of
people who are like [ __ ] these guys like
they're horrible people right and so
like uh I tend to think that like on the
extreme ends usually the truth is like
somewhere in between right and what
you're basically saying is like listen
uh there are people who are doing things
for convenience or for entertainment or
for whatever but it also is a trade-off
with privacy which like I think now
people are waking up to the fact like
yeah if you go and you post a bunch of
photos on the internet and it's a public
profile like anyone can go look at it
like you should probably be careful what
you post on the internet and it's there
forever you can take it down if you want
but it's not really down someone
captured and brought it in and so that's
like the first step I'm guessing right
intelligence hey let's go just Google
around and try to figure out what we can
find this person and then we'll go from
there yeah a powerful tool Google but so
back to the subpoena though so the when
kind of the stops on us so we knew his
mic or his name was I think it's Mike I
might just be making that up but we uh
send him we send a subpoena request over
to the USA and say we need all the mics
that go to a high school in any
enrichment or any of the surrounding
counties and the areas is like there's
no [ __ ] way you're not we're not
doing that and so there is a check and
balance so like because it was a hot
case I mean the director was involved
because the director's daughter had been
part of their attack these guys went
after after her oh so they were like
[ __ ] with the FBI they were [ __ ]
with everybody yeah so so yeah I mean it
took a personal route at one point
um you know so
it you know there is a check and balance
there where we're not we're not even go
to the grand jury with that request
you're crazy to high school kid you're
talking about school records you know
but we took a shot you know we were we
couldn't get any further with the case
and this is what we needed but we
cracked it anyways okay so in those
types of scenarios uh I don't know all
the details but I'm gonna say that
that's like uh uh High School menaces
using online tools if if what they're
doing is they're harassing people you're
being a menace it's bad you shouldn't do
it like go after it if it's bomb threats
now you've kind of like crossed over
into another thing if you're actually
like inciting or committing violence you
like kind of Ratchet up more and more
the uh the severity I think and the
importance probably yeah
how do you delineate where to actually
put the resources so you guys are
sitting there there's a million things
that you could go do is it like the
director or somebody is just like okay
this team you're gonna go do work on
this now or are you all sitting there
saying like we have six different cases
that we could go look at let's do kind
of like a risk reward type analysis and
then like go spend six months working on
a case it doesn't really the direct
doesn't get involved in that sort of
thing I mean unless it's a you know
obviously if the director's family
somehow involved it kind of you know
trickles down people are paying
attention but it's more I mean that sort
of decision making is more on the like
the supervisor of the squad on where the
resources are at the right place and
that's normally a guy that's been on for
at least seven years uh hopefully he
worked on that squad or worked that
offense before so he kind of knows where
the resources to go in this case we were
talking about just a second ago with the
the kid they were involved in swatting
they kind of brought swatting to the
Forefront where we were starting to see
some some real negative outcomes too you
know yes SWAT teams to people's houses
and so I think as you kind of look at
this
that is you know there's like bomb
threats or swatting like you kind of
Ratchet up there how much of like the
Cyber crimes that you guys were dealing
with would be on the like there's
potential violence involved right versus
like there's like buying drugs there's
like still things that are criminal
activity but like it's not violent crime
is there like a percentage that you
could look at is I don't know how long
you were in that like 10 years or
whatever but like what percent was
actually like violent stuff versus like
when people think of online I think a
lot of times they think of like oh
there's no violence to this it's just
like playing around in the digital world
um I think actual people dying or you
know very low
um and we said we say that once in a
while but like you know we get the call
in the middle of the night on a Saturday
night after you know a night out be like
did anybody die I mean do I really have
to come in uh you know it's kind of just
like one of those those check things but
but you know everything has a potential
I mean Silk Road has reported deaths to
it and murders to it
um again people renting out their
children
um
as a father to me that's almost almost
as bad as death
um okay so you guys uh you know about
Bitcoin you're mining Bitcoin now how do
we get from that to like uh Silk Road so
in the middle there there was a case
called lulsec
um which is a group of hackers they were
kind of part of anonymous
um and we ended up finding the leader of
uh LOL sticker and named Hector monster
gor Sabu at the time sort of we call
them so the Kaiser so save hacking
around then
um and why'd you call him that
way so you have to tell people what's
going on and so you know he kind of was
like this
guy that was mystical on the internet
and people feared him other hackers
feared him they're like
um because he would just get you uh the
worst thing that happened to a hacker I
think is being doxxed
um and you know the real identity
putting out there and people just didn't
want to screw with taboo Sabu had some
you know there's a lot of people that
front that they hack on the internet
there's very few that actually do it
yeah
um you know he was good he was good and
he you know he put his name out there
there's a lot of hackers that are good
that just don't say anything yeah they
just do it and go about their work he
kind of he branded himself he branded
himself as this this you don't you don't
[ __ ] with me type guy got it uh and why
did you guys start to go after them were
they doing similar type of stuff or low
SEC was had their so anonymous had this
thing around Wikileaks uh with PayPal
Mastercard and started hacking into
stuff and getting in the news
um then lol SEC started having their 50
days of Terror they didn't leave with
the 50 days at the time they didn't know
it yet
um but then they went after uh really
what got our attention is they went
after an FBI Affiliated site a place
called infraguard so and then they
started have a thing called uh FFF or
[ __ ] FBI Friday so they were they were
swinging at the FBI every Friday in law
enforcement
um that's gonna raise our attention Okay
uh and I'll caveat this entire
conversation with like I know enough to
be dangerous but like definitely not an
expert in any of this so if I screw up
correct me
um so they start out is it the
equivalent of like kind of petty crime
and then they start to like sophisticate
over time and then it kind of builds and
builds and builds and then almost to
some degree it sounds like you begin to
like get comp you're like almost like
looking for the attention where you're
like what can we what can we do to just
go bigger and bigger every time is that
like generally how these groups work
yeah I got away with it now how it you
know they were in the news every day I
mean they they you know they were
putting out these big hacks and you know
the beginning they had 500 000 followers
on Twitter I mean this was a hacking
group there's a criminal organization
that had fans yeah well at the time
Twitter wasn't that big I mean that was
a lot of followers back so when
this may be hard to do but take yourself
out of your seat and put it in their
seat what are they trying to accomplish
at the time like what was your
understanding of what they were trying
to accomplish or was it just like cause
chaos lulls I mean it was it really
their motto was for the lulls they were
doing it because it was funny to [ __ ]
with you yeah like they could have I
mean they could have shorted stuff they
could have short you know they could
have before they hacked into a major
business they could have shorted it and
made it a little money yeah the SEC is
probably going to find that pretty
quickly and then you know those
transactions then you're tracing the
money which is pretty easy
um so maybe they were smart to not do it
that way so in some way it's almost like
uh it's harder to catch somebody who
isn't trying to make money off of it
yeah right so like I lose that path that
Financial cyber crime two pass money is
an IP uh if money's not involved then I
only have one path I can follow yeah
it's it's uh it's fascinating okay so uh
so they start going and they said FFF
[ __ ] FBI Friday what are they doing on
[ __ ] FBI Friday every Friday they would
dump something there somehow
tangentially uh attributed to the FBI or
some sort of law enforcement stuff off
so I'm trying to embarrass the FBI yeah
yeah and there was a hacker that came in
the guy going by the name of anarchaos
who like that was his sole mission was
just to [ __ ] with cops just hated cops
and would dump anything I mean and dump
means like he somehow hacked something
got records and then like just puts it
out on the dark web and anyone can look
at it or what exactly yeah I mean so
puts it out anywhere I mean whereas
lossek was dumping it every on just uh
social media wherever they could
um they weren't hiding anything so these
ones much they want as many eyeballs on
this information as possible yes police
information stuff they would use uh
police tactics sources within the police
anything that was you know behind that
that wall of secrecy for the law
enforcement okay so uh
I'm coming at this from my only
experience really with law enforcement
like communities Etc is the military
right uh there's a lot of [ __ ] that's
been leaked from the military that if
you were directly involved with it
you're like [ __ ] this this is bad like
you know you guys shouldn't do that
whatever there's other things that get
leaked from the military that I think
people in the military like
ah military should have been doing that
right like kind of almost like hey I
don't like the fact that somebody went
and hacked it and released it but like
by the way like it may be on is a net
positive over the long run because
somebody did do that
how do you evaluate the stuff that they
were doing is it like all like really
dumb [ __ ] and it's just like oh they
were just [ __ ] with us and like there
was nothing really there or there are
things that like in hindsight you're
like okay these guys shouldn't have been
doing this it was wrong they broke the
law but whatever we went in and caught
them but like the information was
actually like pretty explosive stuff
like how should we rate it I don't get
to rate it I don't get to judge it okay
you know it's you know it's a violation
of 18 USC 1030 yep uh you know and the
fact that you have that memorized means
you really were [ __ ] focused on this
I mean that's my life so I mean I had to
go after I mean I didn't get to pick and
choose no I'm not saying at the time
yeah I mean more so like uh the the
severity of what they're leaked is this
like holy [ __ ] uh they're trying to like
claim the FBI's corrupt or is it like uh
oh look at these guys we like released
to their uh I don't know who their uh um
uh people feed them information is and
like we're just trying to embarrass them
uh it was more when the embarrassing
side some companies didn't I mean they
had some information that they
definitely didn't want to put out there
um I mean look at the severity so Hector
montserger was arrested here in the
United States he was facing 125 years in
prison that's a lot his uh two other
guys that were also part of lossec they
were over in Ireland they were slapped
on their wrist and sent back to college
so
same crimes they speak more to what they
were doing or more to the different
justices different Justice systems so I
mean it's it's probably somewhere in the
middle yeah yeah hold on just repeat
that again
what so three guys same group doing the
same [ __ ] six guys total six guys yep
the guy that gets arrested in the United
States American citizen yep and you are
you guys friends with we are very close
friends now we actually have a podcast
together okay all right so yeah I know
yeah I I arrested one of my closest
friends it's a very strange relationship
can I give you uh my reaction so for
those that don't know how some of these
podcasts come together somebody emailed
me was like hey there's this guy he's
really fascinating like you should talk
to him I was like who the [ __ ] this guy
Google right and then all of a sudden on
the same email somebody's like hey by
the way the guy he arrested also wants
to come on and I was like do I need
security for that like like wait wait so
I went down and I was like this is
[ __ ] crazy so the guy Hector who gets
arrested here in the United States he's
an American citizen yes at the time okay
he still is American citizens okay he
gets faced with 125 years in prison but
the guys in Ireland who get arrested who
I guess are not American citizens no
they were Irish citizens they just go
back to high school uh they're in
college or whatever yeah yeah pretty
much I mean
yeah but that's crazy but it is but I
mean we made a deal that they were
charged in the United States but their
arrest warrants are sent in a file
somewhere we didn't file like a red
notice or anything that if they traveled
they'd be extradited why would you guys
not do that uh that was the deal a bunch
of prosecutors so the Irish prosecutors
came over to New York we sat down and we
talked about it and all that and it was
it politically it worked out some way
that way and there was about negotiating
and things that people may not
understand that kind of happen in these
cases especially when they're
multi-jurisdictional or multi-country or
whatever sure yeah and I think I mean a
lot of it was that you know we had
Hector Hector and I sat by Sat by side
by side for like eight months working on
cyber crime so Hector leader of
anonymous leader of lossec rested him
flipped him to work with the FBI so we
said what's that like flipping him yeah
or you just walking in like yo bro you
work for us now like let's get to work
or is he like literally you arrest
someone he's like I [ __ ] hate you
guys uh I mean he was true to Spirit we
sat at his kitchen he you know he led us
in his house he didn't have to we sat at
his kitchen table because you guys
showed up to arrest him yeah we showed
up to the rest of them there's a
surveillance team that was watching him
all day and then someone had doxed him
uh that night and so
the doxing usually happens before the
surveillance team
but there's a surveillance team who you
guys already knew who he was or thought
you knew who he was yeah well obviously
knew who he was yeah who he was but you
thought it was the person Cebu or
whatever yeah we we knew Sabu I mean we
knew that Sabu was Hector monster your
okay and we put a surveillance team on
him to watch what was going on and okay
why when you make that connection do you
not just go arrest immediately uh
building the case I mean we had to you
know get all the information we still
had search warrants coming back from
different accounts and that sort of
thing so we wanted to make sure we had
it you know dead to rights and when you
have a search warrant uh it's like super
new on stuff uh and you go and let's say
you get bank account information like
does the bank tell the person nope
so you kind of crazy you file it under
seal so once the case all comes out then
the judge lifts that seal so yeah when
you when you ask for the search warrant
you also ask the judge to make an order
of it for under seal so because it's an
ongoing investigation okay so uh
surveillance team's watching this guy
you guys already know who who he is
um I'll sell you in cyber crime and
we'll probably talk about with the Ross
albrook arrest yeah
I mean well you have all this
information and all that but it could be
wrong I mean they're very good at
obfuscating their their identities I
mean
um are there cases where they like make
you think they're somebody else and then
you guys go and you're like oh [ __ ] this
isn't the right person
um yeah we've had that we've definitely
had that where we you know I didn't yeah
but someone on my squad certainly we we
track somebody and went to their work
was looking or watching them and all
that and like like we had a surveillance
team on them we had night vision on them
and all that and like messages were
going up on Twitter and all like and
they're like well maybe he had his phone
in his pocket and he could do all this
and we're like then this is an agent
holding on strong that she has the right
guy or like there's no way he tweeted a
coherent message with his hand in his
pocket looking forward because we're
watching on the video as the Tweet comes
out they're like come on a little
stronger but it's like pretty
sophisticated I mean if you're literally
trying to match like Hey we're live
watching and there's a tweet like you
start to like really do this yeah I mean
yeah that so I'm sure that's the whole
Ross thing so putting Ross as DPR was
was a big deal okay so uh if we go back
to Hector and uh uh sabu sabu was his
online okay uh you have the surveillance
team there he gets doxxed very
interesting that the surveillance team
is there and there's a doxing you're
smiling so like are you guys doxing him
no definitely no because we wanted to
build the case no that that's where his
old [ __ ] moment uh I was sitting around
in like a t-shirt and shorts uh and we
have to go you know the my boss wasn't
there and his boss wasn't there it was
like late like six o'clock on a Thursday
night or something like that
um and so like somebody else like
finally got Sabu yeah we know who it is
okay so somebody somebody gets them and
they dock some and then you guys but
they never know it's real
like they're just putting the
information out there like he was doxed
as 20 different people got it got this
person just happened to get it right
when we were watching okay and so you
guys move because you're scared he's
gonna like run or like yeah get out of
there got it okay destroy evidence
whatever he's gonna do to get the hell
out of there so like uh sorry if it's
too detail-oriented but do you just like
go knock on his door yeah that's exactly
what we did so uh okay we run out again
I'm in shorts and a t-shirt and I have
my bullets but this is like a oh [ __ ]
like we got to get there quick my boss's
boss went he stopped by NYPD to get us
the sledgehammer and a ballistic shield
because we didn't have any of this stuff
ready it was like this like real game on
yeah we didn't you know yeah because you
because you guys think that uh when I
hear sledgehammer and ballistic shield
like you're not going because you think
he's going to offer you pastries at the
[ __ ] front door is it do you think
that these people are armed or it's just
like no this is all precaution like we
always do every time yeah every time you
go prepared but normally we have a plan
it's six a.m and we're gonna go in you
know we have everything mapped out we're
gonna know which way the door opens
we're gonna know we're in or out I mean
we practice all this stuff before we go
and do an arrest okay
you go knock on the door and you said he
invites you in well he opened the door a
crack and when you open a crack how you
learn from being a street cop you kind
of put your foot there so the door maybe
is not going all the way back close yep
um and you know he comes out in the
hallway and starts talking to us and we
convince him maybe you don't want to
talk your neighbors here hear what's
going on you're you know you're or he
lived in a neighborhood that you really
didn't want to see him talking to law
enforcement openly got it so maybe we
want to make this more private and
remind him of that got it and so uh then
he invites you in after you have
reminded him of that detail uh are you
guys like where's your computer or like
what like just walk me through like what
happened so we sit down in his kitchen
table and we sit there and talk and it's
me and another agent
um and there's like six agents out in
the hall uh ballistic Shields vests and
all that they're just standing out there
they're around the corner so it looks a
little strange
um and we said you know yeah where's the
computer and he goes I don't have a
computer and I look over to the left and
there's a power cord uh that sticks out
a laptop power cord there's a flashing
modem up on the show off and all that so
I let him just keep talking and talking
finally I point this out to her I said I
said you know there's these two things
stop don't [ __ ] with me where are they
you know and he's like okay there's a
laptop somewhere uh uh I threw it out
the window we're on the sixth floor I'm
like oh [ __ ]
um so we just keep talking and talking
it was it took about two hours until he
finally said that I am Sabu
um yeah it took him that way to start
off with I don't have a computer until I
threw it out the window did he actually
throw it out no I was hidden in one of
the bedrooms okay uh when you finally
get him to say the computer's there not
out the window
um
do you just like are you like login
um no no we you know you kind of
once that relief of the identity and the
lies you've been holding people kind of
like it's like ah yeah they just want to
talk and you just sit there and listen
you don't you don't didn't admit to
everything uh not everything he thought
he could social engineer US and kind of
pick and choose what and that that's a
multi-day process of going through what
he's going to protect and not protect we
just had a conversation the other day
and he told me about something he always
protected and never told me oh so he's
still he's still got stuff but not
really like crimes because he admitted
all his crime so you have well once he
decided to work with the FBI you have
it's called Princess for a day
um you literally say every princess for
a day yeah you literally talk about
every crap this one day I sped on the
highway and I did 58 miles an hour okay
they write that down you're exonerated
of all of it you're charged with all of
it so they charge you with every crime
you ever did and if you mentioned it in
that part of the deal then the
government can't go back and charge you
again for it really you literally sit
there and you talk about everything
I don't know how I feel about that why
like the speeding all that type of stuff
right it's like a federal crime yeah of
course right but like uh let's just say
like the small stuff it's like uh that
is unrelated to the case I almost feel
like when you flip them but again my
uneducated view from the outside would
be like oh we are going to exonerate you
for things related to this crime but
like I guess people who would commit
some of these crimes also did a bunch of
other stuff too and so like maybe in
some way you're trying to like build
confidence and then they're like hey you
work with us now or gotta make everyone
clean and witness because now if you're
working with the FBI you're going to
become a witness to crimes okay and so
you don't want them to be on the stand
testifying against somebody else and the
defense says well you did this this and
this and you know oh [ __ ] moment for the
government yeah you come clean to
everything you do you get charged with
it and that goes all into the report of
you know fast forward how fast for the
end of it you know 125 years for
everything you're getting cleaned drew
the judge thanked him for his service as
he and he walked out of court that day a
descendancy so so what is the deal that
he streak that he strikes
um that he proposes the deal do you guys
propose the deal or is he like I'll work
for you we propose the deal like when
you're arrested you don't you don't have
any idea how the FBI works I mean it's
all you know it's flashes and lights and
years and you know you don't know what's
going on I'm probably hoping you just go
take a nap yeah
um you know the deal was work with us
and so normally think about like
um the mafia uh I'm gonna arrest the
street level guy I'm gonna work up to
the under boss and then get arrested the
big guy we had the big guy I mean
literally we had the head of wallsack
the head guys what the [ __ ] are we gonna
do with him we didn't really know what
was going on in the hacking world the
time yeah so is he excited about this
like now that he's like okay [ __ ] they
caught me like is he just I almost think
of it as like uh
um I was listening to a podcast recently
talking about Kobe Bryant and uh Michael
Jordan and they love basketball so much
that Michael Jordan uh uh forced the
Chicago Bulls to put in his contract
something called the Love of the Game
clause which meant that uh usually in
these NBA contracts you're not allowed
to play basketball outside of NBA
sanctions things because they want you
to get hurt or whatever and he's like no
literally if I'm driving down the street
and I see a basketball game I want to be
able to go play and they were like uh
okay you're Michael Jordan like sure uh
I'm assuming that there's some hacker
shoes like I just like hacking like
almost like I'll switch teams back and
forth and I just enjoy it like it's
almost like the Love of the Game or was
it like no [ __ ] I'm gonna go to jail for
125 years I'm like I better [ __ ] go
work for these guys I mean so and he was
also a foster parent to two of his uh
nieces okay so that you know yeah didn't
use that against him yes but it's a
mitigating factor in his mind of what
was happening in his life and you know
my thing is you know you're gonna go to
jail tonight we're gonna probably go
upstairs we're gonna process you and
you're going to go over MCC is not a
nice place
um you know or you can work with us and
you're going to be back home tonight you
know we took in the middle of the night
we brought them in the morning and we
had him there in time to bring the his
girls to uh to school the next day wow
yeah all right so uh he doesn't get 125
years what do you guys start doing
together first
everything he's taboo people sent him I
mean people he didn't have to hack
people were just sending hacks this dude
was literally like the [ __ ] Babe Ruth
of hacking
um
if people were scared of Babe Ruth okay
so people wanted to be near him people
wanted to just associate with him be
like like almost Kiss the Ring sometimes
it felt a little weird to be honest so
it's more like John Gotti yeah maybe
yeah yeah sorry yeah the fear of that
I've never put it that way but that's a
perfect thing yeah um you know and they
would bring him hacks be like hey I
broke into these military institutes
hear this these things are hacked into
he had 306 military say I call him saves
uh you know things that were broken into
in the US military that we stopped
because they just jumped on his computer
because somebody sent it to him we'd be
sitting at a desk in the back in the FBI
and somebody would be having a
conversation he'd have like 12 windows
open having conversations with people
like oh hey this is vulnerable here's
the vulnerability here's the hack uh if
you want the dump here it is and no one
knew that he was working with you guys
no one had any idea
and they had contingency plans too that
was the cool thing about so his crew had
hacked into a
um the water supply system a major U.S
city and they were sitting on that and
they had hacked into I'll tell you if we
turn the mics off a major portion of the
government uh and was sitting on an
email server of that
um and they could have leaked at all at
any point that was the plan if someone
got arrested and word got out that they
got arrested we're dumping it that was
the plan internally
um and we worked flawlessly enough that
uh that he never they never found out he
was working on it uh to another Point uh
this is another fun story we just I just
told the podcast the other day
um that
there was a guy in Ireland one of the
underlings there was lower Channel
hackers the six guys in the little
segment that people under it uh this guy
his dad worked for his was part of the
the uh IRA and taught him security and
all that sort of thing and uh he knew
that he lived in Ireland that didn't
have a lot of uh cyber cops in the Garda
and so he hacked into the main cop's
email and just sat on it and he saw all
the traffic of the [ __ ] cops emails
yeah well the made the major cyber cop
the his emails
he sat there and waited he didn't know
when he would use it but he used it
um there was a every Thursday we had a
phone call uh we would talk to the
guarda and the met and all the other
people involved and this was a pretty
case you know in the FBI and so it grew
everybody wanted to have a little piece
of it join the call bosses and all that
so it was like 50 people
um yeah [ __ ] so I'd send over the phone
number and passcode and logging all in
all that and so we had the phone call
and talked and probably talked for like
half an hour you know this is going
forward we're gonna move this forward
and I led the call because I was the
case agent in the U.S side we had the
major source they had their people and
they were watching them and all that
that night about 12 30 I got a call from
Hector frantic and all that
I woke up I was working like 18 hour
days it was like seven days a week it
was crazy drinking from a fire hose
literally and he's frantic and I'm dude
I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about he says I'm gonna send you
something take a listen so I stand in
bed and hit uh hit my iPad hit play and
it was a 28 minute auto file of that
phone call I had that day it was an FBI
phone call I had that day with the guard
of the met and law enforcement all over
the world
and the lulsec underlings had that
[ __ ] recording and they released it
they so
they I sent over the username the login
number and the thing they just logged in
first I didn't hear the beep at the
beginning of the call and they recorded
the whole [ __ ] phone call and then
they the the kid he was smart he sent it
to the one person he knew he could trust
he sent it to Taboo
didn't release it send it to saboon
to to deal with so who's the leader
guess what I was never you guys never
mentioned him never like whatever on the
calls we talked about having a guy we
never said Sabu we never said Hector ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] luck man no way that that
was planned that I didn't say oh so oh
that was just like your [ __ ] luck
holy yeah yeah the gig would have been
up right then and there that kid would
have said that sends it to Sabu and now
he thinks him and Sabu know a secret
that no one else knows so the
relationship grows stronger now he's
like sending whatever yeah there's
somebody on the inside uh we know
there's somebody on the inside we might
be [ __ ] so let's tighten up our
security holy [ __ ] yeah that got me on a
plane over to Ireland the next day did
you guys pick him up uh we didn't but I
was there for his arrest no we we waited
but we had to go over and tell the guy
we couldn't email him
so so if you're the top cyber crunk uh
like cop I guess in Ireland and you get
hacked and then the FBI shows up to tell
you that you're hacked with your
reaction not happy yeah I mean it was it
wasn't pleasant I don't know what the
outcome was in the whole thing but yeah
it did not it didn't go over well okay
so like now you almost have like uh
you've got the John Gotti of hacking
let's call them and people are just
sending them all this [ __ ] like how long
does this go on for eight months for
eight months straight nobody knew nope
and so how many arrests does this lead
to like it's just like really spidering
out now and you're like oh we're [ __ ]
winning yeah I mean really came down to
the arrest of Jeremy Hammond it was the
guy enter chaos the guy in Chicago
um we had to guess Jeremy Jamie's arrest
or no just like what what he did like
well he was the guy that enter chaos
that was uh sending all the police
information and it was just getting out
of control so once we he was using Tor
uh we couldn't figure out who he was for
a long time uh it was found out we
collected all the chats we gave them to
a junior guy and he found all these
different things about it like Jeremy
and her chaos talked about do I was
involved in a fight at this RNC event
one year uh and so and we pull all the
arrest records for that event I did this
I get my internet this way so I had to
be we knew we had to be a cold City
ended up being in Chicago this guy he
had been arrested previously and he was
an anarchist friegan
living in Chicago and so we uh we
finally figured out who he was
um fun story for him uh we we figured
out that he lived in the back bedroom uh
in the house and we needed to get the
laptop we needed to get it open the
hardest part you needed to get open y
evidence we need the evidence we need to
make sure what he had because if it's
not open then they can just wipe it with
like one one keystroke it could be it
could be like a degausser a big magnet
that wipes the hard drive immediately
yeah people talk about it I've never
seen it yeah um but encrypted it's
encrypted strong password it's it's gone
it's yeah good enough so so air gap
closing the air gap that distance
between the fingers and the keyboard
that's really what you have to get and
that's what juries now want because of
CSI and all that [ __ ] uh they need
they need who is typing on the computer
when the hacking happened and so we
needed Jeremy online so we put saboo are
you [ __ ] serious like you literally
have to get him the if somebody's
committing a crime now it's literally
like we need it in the act
if they're gonna fight it yeah I mean
again [ __ ] you know we'll talk about it
in a few minutes about why it's
important but yeah yeah okay so uh so
you know he's in the back bedroom and
that's where the computer you're
assuming is well so we put him online
with Sabu him in saboos in New York and
our back Squad room talking to Inner
Chaos Online
um we we figured out because of Wi-Fi
stuff he was in the back bedroom using
Wi-Fi on the computer and it was off the
kitchen
um so and this is like uh I know like
local cops even have the ability they've
got like the [ __ ] backpacks that are
able to almost be like the middleman uh
with the uh cell phones usually but like
I'm assuming there's some more
Technologies you can do with computers
as well if you say so okay all right I
just read things on the internet
um so we figured out he was in the back
bedroom
um and uh we by the way Mike everyone
knows this now like whenever I have a
guest that I don't know a lot about like
I just start out with like what is the
dark web as my Google search all right
go ahead um and so we got permission to
use the SWAT team to I think was the
first time the FBI's used a SWAT team to
make an arrest
um and we got to use CCTV so we got to
watch it happen the guys had the cameras
on their helmets and all that
um Jesus Christ they knocked the door
down throw flashbang in boom enter into
the house for a hacker yeah this is a
hacker we're going after cops and you
know and all this other stuff
um they go in and dynamic entry you know
the SWAT team you're in the military
would go into where the most dangerous
situation is as they come in there's
about 20 kids in the front room smoking
pot and so that's where the SWAT team
goes
um this is kind of like a communal house
I guess what we got in there
um the last two guys the SWAT Team guys
through the kitchen door looks to the
right and Jeremy closes the laptop
locked up done
um so so it didn't work
um but we were able to figure out that
the password was uh like qe12345 shut
the [ __ ] up it was the cat's name yeah
we didn't try that one but wait wait
wait wait you're talking about one of
the top hackers in the world or whatever
you know basically he's [ __ ] with
cops all stuff and his password is
literally something that like a
six-year-old kid would think of um
uh but it was long so that's all it
needed to be as long as it had enough
characters a chewy one two three four
five it was uh fairly long and so why
does the links matter because Brute
Force if you're gonna brute force it
open you just you try it's just like a
pat like a one of those bike locks you
know you try zero zero zero zero zero
zero one the longer it is the harder
longer it's going to take to get through
it but we finally to get through it okay
uh how did you find out that it was
chewy one two three four Brute Force oh
really yeah now I don't know if that I
mean the FBI has a lot of computers you
can spread that out over time
um over you know this computer does a
little bit of this and this you know you
can do the passwords that way now that's
not positive that that is his password
that's the problem with Brute Force
that's a password that worked so you
have to say that oh interesting what is
the difference
um there could be another password
whoever wrote the password software you
know two passwords could work it's
theoretical and only done in Labs but
you have to say that I mean you know
it's in computer science it's like
saying a random others there's no such
thing as a random it's pseudo-random
it's the same thing with passwords we're
not positive that's what he typed in but
did I say password that worked did you
ask them no no there's no reason to yeah
how long did it take to brute force it
it's like six months oh okay so it was a
long time yeah but still I'm shocked
that you were able to do it yeah we
didn't it's a you know you try it
because you you have it there most times
it doesn't work if it's much yeah it
doesn't work but every once in a while
it does yeah and would it have been
easier or harder to Brute Force like is
length the only thing that matters or
like if somebody has a password with a
bunch of characters and uh symbols and
all that like so that makes it harder
but uh from our end you have to assume
that it has all the special characters
um there's certain types of things you
can do and we do this in like in uh at
our company we do this with um you know
like crypto recovery certain programs
don't use certain characters and certain
times if you look back in history so it
takes out all those combinations got it
so it makes it a little easier okay so
it like thumbs it down yeah all right so
what happened to that guy uh 10 years
you got 10 years because he's still in
prison nope he's out now okay uh he we
did uh we did a reverse proper for so
with Hector the Queen for a Day it's
called a Prof recession where you tell
everything we in a proper session it's a
proper session so we did a reverse
proper with Jeremy and told him all the
stuff we had against him
and then he's decided to plead guilty
got it so reverse processor proffer is
like Hey we're gonna charge with all
this stuff but if you just plead down
now we're gonna charge you this is all
the evidence we have against you if you
go to trial this is what we're going to
use against you and unbeknownst to him
the program that he was using for
hacking uh stored all his keystrokes so
his whole history of everything he was
doing was on his computer why do they
store all of it it's easier it's easier
to go back and copy and paste or if you
missed something you know
I again I don't know why you would keep
a log of committing a crime but that's
crazy is that the common like every
computer that pretty much has that no no
he was using specialized software yeah
okay all right and how much I guess of
this is like skill versus like they just
know the right software to run
uh Hector and Jeremy were had skills
yeah uh but I mean they also had friends
that would offer him what's called an
oday or a zero day it's a vulnerability
and a software
um so somebody else found the
vulnerability but basically like they
don't got the courage to do it yeah
they're like they're probably they're
probably like do cyber security at a
company during the day but they like to
research and kind of live in that world
at night and they just send it in or
something like that yeah share with
those guys and then uh Sabu or whoever
will go and they'll exploit it because
like that's what they do yeah yeah now
there's in hacking there's teams like
that now you have different teams people
that find the exploits people that
exploit it and then the people that will
go in and dump it out and then the
people that'll sell it I mean they're
all different stages of hackers is this
like the new organized crime yeah yeah
they build teams yeah yeah how prevalent
is it in the world it's bad it's getting
real bad especially you know with these
onion sites that we talked about you
know people like have their pages right
there uh ransomware I mean these guys
have Pages you can go and chat with them
if you want to
so it's crazy
um all right so you get uh the guy in
Chicago yep
how do we get to Silk Road
all right so Jeremy was using Tor uh we
took down Anonymous and you know kind of
that whole thing rested all those guys
Hector is anonymous and LOL anonymous
little SEC and all that and the whole
big takedown got a lot of attention
um we sort of sometimes in the bureau
depending on where you're at
um you do a big case like that you're
working 18 hours a day you work for nine
ten straight months you know the the
boss is like hey go get remember your
family we'll see in a few months
um at the like the cases closing type uh
I don't want to say party because we're
not celebrating people's arrest get
together
um the prosecutor said to us so what's
next it's like what's next I'm gonna go
meet my family I'm gonna go remember
what it's like to not work 18 hour days
but you know we were young and wanted to
get going
um Bitcoin was out there and Jeremy was
using Tor and you know people kind of
saw us like oh you got past tour and I
really we use all those chat logs to
kind of find where he was yeah but we
were finding more and more around that
time this was
end of 11 12 somewhere around there the
FBI cases were coming to an end and just
being closed because oh IP came back to
tour case closed we can't do anything
interesting so we said
let's take a look at this let's see what
we can do what can we find
um and so we opened up a case with uh 27
26 different
um dot onions and Silk Road was number
six on the list
so
this is just a random case
that was using Tor and you guys should
start checking each one of the like
websites uh yeah so again we were doing
computer cyber intrusions at the time so
um
criminal sorry it's criminal cyber
intrusion so
hacking tools hackers for hire and stuff
like that we had a you know the
because of politics we had to find uh
some sort of hacking thing so Silk Road
sold you know hacking dumps and hacking
tools so so if Silk Road never had that
you guys would have never been able to
do anything my squad my squad wouldn't
have gotten involved because rsac at the
time needed some sort of Nexus to
hacking so okay even though the
prosecutor uh the southern district had
been working on Silk Road for a while oh
they had been yeah traditionally through
the DEA um their drugs looking for drugs
and buy their way up just like we talked
about with the mafia they tried to buy
drugs but that person had no idea where
the drugs came from yeah
so you almost have multiple law
enforcement agencies that are trying to
figure this out and at the time did they
understand what it was or are they just
like I don't know like just like we
found somebody who said they bought
drugs here we like have like somebody
bought hacking software here like it was
almost like you knew the outputs but you
didn't really know what that it was a
Marketplace or could you like go on to
the marketplace you go in the
marketplace yeah you knew that it was
like dark web eBay or whatever you want
to call it yeah I think it did
um the senator Schumer had mentioned it
on the the floor of Congress that it
needed to be a problem there's a problem
needed to be taken care of so it was
known out there in law enforcement of
this thing
um and I think as our case in sort of
side inside tour kind of evolved we knew
that Silk Road was sort of the golden
ring
um I say the golden ring but it would be
the biggest splash
so as you're going through this
at what point are you like oh we think
that we have made progress right so I'm
assuming there's a bunch of like things
that you're doing you're talking to
other agencies like whatever and like
people have been trying and trying and
trying we're not talking to very many
people no so it's just you guys were
just doing this is kind of like a
one-off thing yeah
at what point are you like oh we think
we've got something or we we think we've
got an angle or like a uh uh we think we
can make progress here when we came back
from Iceland with a server
explain we had found the server through
law enforcement techniques through you
know uh traditional gumshoot you know
cyber techniques and what's that what
does that mean uh you can't say we yeah
I mean it's all out there publicly it's
a real nuance and all that but we you
know we went to Iceland we met with the
law enforcement there uh they we told
them what the case was we told them what
was going on uh and they opened the case
and they made a copy of the server and
gave us a copy okay so you use whatever
these things are that are probably too
complicated for me to understand uh and
it points to there is one server in
Iceland that is part of the tour network
uh yes so but that's also housing all of
the code
etc for uh Silk Road yeah we didn't know
at the time uh we we believed that at
the time that that's where Silk Road
lived and not until we got back and was
able to take a look at it okay is it
common for these services to live on one
single server or do they kind of get
spread out and back then it was pretty
common to live on one I mean tour is
kind of slow and so spreading it out
kind of and you have mirrors and it
makes it faster because it's on more in
one site
um but back in the day it was pretty
pretty common just having one one all
right so you guys get back with the copy
of the server uh does the server
operator know that a copy has been made
nope no okay so you guys have the copy
uh what do you do
um first we didn't think we could get
into it we thought it was encrypted uh
because it was when we put on our
machine look I was encrypted come to
find out the icelandics encrypted it so
it would be secured coming to us uh so
we got the password from them open it up
and it was wide open it was kind of
surprising uh most times you would
encrypt a server like that but but this
one was just open
um it was the Silk Road the entire
database everything that ever been sold
on it all the records of it everything
was there and plus it's uh it's
Communications Network like who had been
logging into it who you know were the
different IPS it was talking to and all
that uh and there's like real names or
all the uh pseudonyms all pseudonyms
okay
um what do you do once you realize like
basically you got the records we start
mapping things out
um we start you know who's this computer
talking to we do the traditional cyber
investigation you know so we found out
that that computer was making backups to
a server in Philadelphia I got a search
warrant for that and got copies of that
for anything we were missing
um and then tracked all the different
IPS and
um subpoenas went out for the IPS that
were were hitting the server
and as you're watching this
kind of play out I'm assuming you have
like a small team that's working on this
when do you say we have something that
we think connects to uh DPR
um it's a little bit further into that
so there was a meeting down in DC as a
deconfliction meeting and
um we didn't go down to it what is that
uh so all the agencies that have been
working on Silk Road kind of came
together and laid their cards on the
table
is there politics between agencies yes
yeah a lot of a lot of the terms Sweat
Equity was put into it Sweat Equity yeah
like I said I mean I've been working on
this a long time but I'm still nowhere
to go I deserve whatever you found just
because I worked on it for longer that's
how I took it so okay you know I just
so like are all the cards actually laid
on the table or is there like posturing
like
um we have this thing but like we're not
ready to show it to you so I think
there's three different groups there was
a group out of Baltimore doing their
thing that was a whole bunch of
different agencies but not the FBI it
was like Secret Service DEA HSI uh there
was the FBI Us in New York and there was
a guy a lone HSI guy on Chicago named
Jared again
um Jared had he was working at O'Hare
Airport and he saw a package of drugs
come through and through investigation
he figured out that that drugs was a
shipment part of silk road so he opened
up a case on Silk Road and was running
on his own Chicago O'Hare Airport
yep I mean
so that's pretty that's pretty [ __ ]
crazy yeah so you know we were getting a
lot of pressure from the the guys in
Baltimore Sweat Equity and all that to
to the point where I was just telling my
daughter yesterday
um she was asking about like the the
Carl Force who was the de agent and um
she says I remember you talking to him
once and we were on a trip up in in um
so we had had the server and we were on
a family trip up in Vermont and I had to
pull the side of the road because Carl
called me and was like I'm coming down
I'll be there tomorrow I will have the
server you're gonna give me a copy I'm
gonna look through it and all that and I
thought it was just the sweat equities
[ __ ] um come to find out Carl was dirty
and he wanted to know what evidence we
knew about what he was dirty doing so
um that's a whole different story we'll
get to that yeah it's a whole different
story but so
um all right so you guys start to do
this work you go down everyone shows
their cards I didn't go down you didn't
I just went through video okay so
everyone else is there they're showing
cards whatever not the Baltimore guys
they didn't show their cards the only
person that showed their cards was Jared
he stood up and said this is what I got
Chicago this is where I am yeah and come
to find out he had worked his way up as
an undercover and he was working into
the uh the admin it wasn't quite there
but he was working his way up this
[ __ ] worked at the airport and
he it was undercover like just Rogue I
mean he's an agent he was a gun agent so
it wasn't just an airport worker yeah
but he was assigned to the airport that
was his office you know packages coming
in the United States who did he work for
uh HSI Homeland Security investigation
okay all right so like he's working at
the airport but he's part of like the
Homeland Department yeah yeah okay got
it uh and so he worked his way up as an
undercover agent and now is not an admin
but like pretty [ __ ] close pretty
close yeah okay when he tell tells you
all that he's done that and he's got all
his what do you use your guy's reaction
let's partner with him okay because this
other group is trying to you know
exactly yeah push us out and Sweat
Equity [ __ ] all right so you say
let's partner with them what happens now
I called him I said hey this is what we
got
it sounds like you have a good Insight
on the organization what's going on and
he flew up to New York the next day and
we sat down in the back room and we we
talked it through and I I showed him
Silk Road uh Tom Curtin had rebuilt the
server to run to stand on a standalone
computer we could log in as anyone we
could see any chat of any person
um we saw everything the way the back we
did everything how do we get from that
to the library
fast forward and all that and we find
you know Jared makes his way up to admin
um Jared has seen that um we um what is
his name on the site Jared he had a
bunch of different sites I don't
remember which one
um but he made his way up to admin and
Ross had a this time DPR had on a jabber
server
um that they were talking on and we saw
that the jabber server was set to
specific Pacific Coast time so pretty
sure DPR was on and he had said
instructions to all the admins so we had
now we had West Coast
um and it's not like a big deal that
you're like oh at least we know it's the
West Coast
124 every time zones there are that's
not bad for us yeah okay so we're moving
forward that gives a sense for like I
mean it's a little needle and a haystack
to like you know your 124th of the way
there yeah okay we had we had a computer
that oh we knew that admin was logging
into a computer called from a computer
called Frosty so you know when you set
up your computer you name it Frosty was
all he was the main admin coming into
Silk Road all the time and what was
going on
so we knew Frosty
um there was another an IRS agent that
had done some history and looked back uh
in time
um and saw that right around the start
of Silk Road someone had posted on a uh
on a forum that said they needed help
running a underground or a web server
type thing that ran on tour and used
Bitcoins and if you could help them out
um could you reach out at ross.olbrick
gmail.com so our world that's a clue so
we look into this there's a guy named
Ross Albrecht living in the in the um
West Coast in San Francisco
um and he posted that post under the
name Frosty
um so we had our clue of the only
someone that had still growth server
would know that that his computer was
named Frosty and Ross Albrecht that's a
clue started doing surveillance found
out that when DPR was online Ross Albert
was using Tor out of his house
um more clues came together put
everything in an affidavit and flew out
to San Francisco so
do you
find him without that original post
um maybe maybe maybe I don't know but I
mean that was the like Breakthrough at
that point in the investigation yeah I
mean so each piece couldn't be used
independently but put together the
collective was enough to get a 46 page
um you know uh arrest warrant okay when
you guys fly out there like you're going
to arrest them I had the arrest warrant
pocket already been to the judge in
southern district he signed an arrest
warranty and uh for Ross Albrecht AKA
DPR okay
I've read uh I forget the name of the
book uh it talks about in the library
American brain by Nick Bilton Facebook
um
so
my understanding is that he goes to a
public library he's using the internet
there yep
what is this like his hands are on the
computer but you guys get them to
basically take his hands off the
computer so we were at a cafe and
Spotify in San Francisco we stuck out
pretty well uh we get there and I was
just gonna say is it like you know the
whole like local cops Donuts like the
whole thing bulge yeah cargo pants I
mean seriously man we stuck out like
sore thumbs but you're not a tech worker
no no and so
um everyone's just clearing out of the
coffee shop they're like feds pretty
much the first day
um nothing he didn't come out nothing
was going on we had there was a
surrealist team on his house okay
um second day got a call he left his
house and has a laptop bag over his over
his
um chest uh carrying it
and we're in a cafe just kind of sitting
there waiting down the street around the
corner
um I come we all leave I leave and take
a left going the crosswalk and he's
right there in the crosswalk we face to
face I mean
throw them on the ground or rest him
case closed I let him go
I don't know this part of the story so
when you walk out of the cafe you go
left and he's right there in the cross
in the crosswalk we we we cross you have
to arrest warrant with you if you're in
my pocket and you don't let him go okay
why Jeremy Hammond I had to arrest him
with his keys on the finger like if that
thing was encrypted or we he had said
that maybe he had a degausser you know
something to ruin the evidence I needed
that laptop the laptop was more
important than the person at the time
okay so uh
I'm gonna make a connection to what you
just said
um if it wasn't law enforcement it
wasn't the raw situation because I know
there's there's a lot of people who have
different views on this response I want
to make sure that you have a chance to
kind of talk about from your perspective
but sure uh let's just say that you were
in business and uh you had an experience
you learned from it and you did it again
that is a story as old as time but in
some way from a law enforcement
perspective a previous event that you
guys had been involved in you actually
learned and adjusted your tactics right
whether people agree with it or not and
that's why you don't end up arresting
them right there a thousand percent it's
the only reason I did not throw them to
the ground and arrest him right there is
the arrest of Jeremy Hammond and
learning from that okay so where does he
go like you pass though pass him are you
like immediately like on a walkie-talkie
or do you have a cool earpiece and
you're like no no no no no no because
this is like I'm already okay
I'm already sticking out so and I look
like a cop you know so you know I go
fast and I take a right and go across
the street and hopefully somebody else
is watching him and they are uh and
we're just texting it's just a text
chain going back and forth there's no
radio communications we don't have
radios we don't have radios that work
yeah um because we're from New York
um I I brought Tom Kiernan with me he
was uh he and I brought Jared Dairy
again and I brought another guy named
Todd with me um out out there all New
York guys well Jared's a Chicago guy
he goes into the cafe we were just in
realize it's a little crowded in there
for him so he goes next door to the
library and he goes upstairs and he sits
in a window Jared and I kind of circle
around and come back and we sit on a
park bench outside a hardware shop
um and can see up in the window that
Ross is sitting at a table and opens up
his laptop uh Jared so you guys can
literally see we can literally see him
Jared opens his laptop and now I always
say that maybe Ross was a little kind of
understood that maybe I'd look for
police cars coming or something like
that you know um that's why I sat by the
window I have no idea
um Jared opens his laptop sit on his
bench and we see that DPR just logged in
I got Ross with a computer open just
opened DPR just logged in okay so this
is like kind of a crazy thing but like
this is the first day you ever see him
in person yep
and like the sidewalk when I it's like
game on yeah
so like you've you have now visually
seen Ross for less than 30 minutes 20
minutes
and like 20 seconds yeah and now you're
already like okay cool game on yeah
Jesus okay
how do you get from bench to so he opens
it up starts logging Jared sends him a
personal message see a guy or see the
guy up there typing message comes back
back and forth kind of students reaction
100 we got our guy this is we've closed
that air gap good to go
um there was a surveillance team on uh
on Ross and like
surveillance teams are really good in
the FBI like you would never know that
you're the surrounding team Hector will
tell you today that he knew he had a
surveillance team on it I didn't think
he's [ __ ]
I'll tell him to his face I think it's
[ __ ] but he swears he knew it was
coming but Ross didn't Ross sits to this
table opens the laptop he's running his
Billion Dollar Empire
um at the table a little uh uh uh a
female agent maybe five feet tall maybe
sits down across the table from in plain
clothes and she starts reading a book
um
Ross's
drugs are in it up uh and then a female
agent an older female agent and a male
agent walk in behind Ross and um you
know everyone knows I said get the
laptop the laptop is an important part
we'll get Ross he's not getting out of
the library it's a laptop so the older
female agent [ __ ] back
punches the manager right in the jaw
I heard that there was a disturbance I
don't think I knew that they punched him
the older female agent who's walking
behind Ross punches the mail agent the
male agent to create a distraction okay
boss turns around the female agent takes
the laptop and slides it across the
table hands it to Tom Kiernan and Tom
Kiernan's job was to keep it alive
so that was it we had the laptop and you
were worried that if he
touched it whatever something could
happen it could lock control delete so
what did Tom Kiernan what it was his his
job we had bought
um we bought a battery pack and every
single adapter possible for any laptop
ever
um to plug it in keep it alive and keep
hitting spacebar and just keep taking he
took pictures screenshots of the
pictures so that ended up in in the
newspaper later after that of you know
Mastermind it was always in it was in
his trial you know that this was The
Mastermind the main login for a little
set right after a little sick for Silk
Road and that was the computer Ross was
sitting at in the library the pictures
have the library in the background
spacebar just keep it up just keep it
alive keep it from walking we had no
idea how long you know what the security
features were of when it would lock out
or anything like that
um so Punch Yeah laptop and then you
arrest him well Ross stands up a little
bit and Todd pushes him back down in the
chair as the arresting agent you never
want to be the guy that goes Hands-On
why because you want to build that
Rapport you don't want to take his
freedom from him let somebody else do do
that I don't know if there's a lot of
new agents that do that they don't teach
that in the academy yeah you want to
work with them
um so don't take his freedom away let
somebody else do that so Todd Hancock
uses my handcuffs handcuffs them up
um I bring him down I'm at the top of
the stairs I bring about halfway down to
the bottom of the stairs
um agents kind of seal off the library
because people are like what the hell is
going on there's a bunch of planes
clothes gotten no idea the FBI is in an
operation yeah I Frisk Ross you know one
of the other things turn them around one
of the first things I always do is I put
my hand right in their chest you know
human connection I wanna you know are
you you know he's okay he's about her
heart attack I mean I've never been
arrested by the FBI it's got to be a
very stressful day yeah
um he's fine we talk go out to the car
and that's why I finally show him his
arrest paperwork that said you know his
name and DPR and I think things kind of
set in from there and he is like you got
me nope oh no he's gonna fight it lawyer
go okay read him his rights no more
questions and that was it okay
um
in hindsight what was he arrested for
um I don't know what the initial charge
is so you charge someone with everything
you have right there uh in front of you
and then you supersede the indictment
after the arrest
um within our foundation or whatever
yeah yeah what we find What We Gather
from the search for we did execute a
search warrant on his house right after
that and so the interface we find there
I don't remember what the original did
you find a lot of obviously the
computer's got a ton of information but
you already had the server so like you
had a lot of information whatever uh in
the house and stuff like that did you
find more I didn't do the search of the
house I took Ross to jail
um Jared stayed behind and did the
search of the house with uh the local
San Francisco FBI so I mean that's a
kind of a strange story so we were
supposed to we flew out to New York I
meet with the San Francisco
um Casey the supervisor cyber supervisor
and we sit down and we talk about uh
Silk Road and what's going on why I'm
there and all that
um and he says all right so we're gonna
make a plan we're gonna go in and we're
gonna arrest Ross with a SWAT team and I
see you know I can't do that you know
like I I did that before I tell the
Jeremy story and all that and it doesn't
work and he's like all right all right
and he says all right how about this
we'll send in three SWAT teams
and he had some idea of like a helic
helicopter and rappelling and basements
and all that and I said well give me a
couple days and so he gave me a couple
days the government shut down working at
this time so we're all working for free
and uh that's in that two days was when
Ross came out and we we arrested him
so the next day was supposed to be the
SWAT teams and we were doing it because
he was the boss out there he was in
charge I just remember them so we called
them uh right after the arrest when
we're sitting Ross is sitting in a van
um and all we heard is a bunch of New
York [ __ ] Cowboys that's what they
called us really yeah
so as you
think about it now
um I'm gonna go to the critics of the
FBI first uh there's a lot of people in
the Bitcoin Community uh specifically
but maybe even broader than just Bitcoin
who say hey uh the War on Drugs is dumb
uh this guy was running uh online drug
market like he didn't kill anybody uh he
shouldn't be in jail especially he
should have got sentenced for as long as
possible like
I won't get all of the critics arguments
but I'm sure you've heard them plenty
um how do you think about them is there
any weight or do you put any
um accuracy to the to any of the
critiques or do you feel like uh no you
guys don't understand the details or
whatever I think there's some of that
and it's not the FBI's job to send to
somebody there's there's judges that do
that judges and juries I mean a jury of
the way how the system works the jury
found him guilty they they returned a
verdict in three hours
um which is pretty quick for a jury
trial and I think they even had a lunch
break in the middle there
um and then the judge sentenced them um
I was surprised by the sentence but
again it's not for me to pass judgment
that's you know that wasn't my job my
job was to bring him to Justice and then
the jury and the judge comes up with the
the with guilty or not in the in the
sentencing Okay so
the arrest itself was for operating the
marketplace it wasn't so much for uh I
thread things about hits and like all
this kind of other stuff but like you
guys were cyber crime hey we got a guy
who's running this it's illegal we're
gonna go arrest him
what you're basically saying is like we
arrest them and then you essentially
hand them over to like a district
attorney or whatever the United States
Attorney okay Southern industry in New
York prosecuted this guy it's like the
District Attorney's bosses bosses boss
or whatever uh district attorney are
more cities
um this is federal level and the federal
okay so when you hand it there then it's
like whatever they want to charge them
with the judges the sentencing like kind
of the thing takes off
given kind of the work that you did up
front build the case do all the stuff
and you see the sentence like
I don't know how to really think about
like maybe you don't have an opinion on
like is the sentence appropriate or is
it not right like because it's like I
certainly don't have a public opinion I
have opinions okay you want to share it
no all right all right
um and so when you think about that
entire situation like what are like the
big lessons because I think this is like
an interesting piece right it's like
there's a lot of people who in hindsight
hindsight's well maybe it's not 20 20
but like it's pretty clarifying for
people in terms of like what someone was
doing how it went like all the stuff
what are the lessons learned well for me
I mean I I I shouldn't predict anything
I thought this would be the fall of
cryptocurrency really uh yeah and I
thought that this would definitely be
the fall of uh dark Market websites I
mean Ross was sentenced to two life
sentences plus 40 years I mean that
that's more than El Chapo
um but since then I think we kind of
just made the we made dark Market
websites more popular
um certainly my mother had never heard
of dark Market websites before uh Silk
Road was put in the papers
um so maybe we popularized some more I
don't know
I've thought about that a lot so you
thought that uh the arrest of Ross
Albrecht and the bringing down of Silk
Road was going to actually end Bitcoin I
thought it was going to take a big hit I
mean I thought people would start seeing
it as more of a criminal tool
um because I mean that's the world I
live in I live in where I I mean I I
think again we talked to the you know
I'm a technologist I like the technology
moving forward but my world sees the bad
side of crypto all the time and I
thought maybe the you know once Silk
Road came out there and what was
happening on Silk Road you know the mom
and pops of the world would then see oh
well crypto's bad
when you were doing this inside the FBI
was like Bitcoin equals illegal activity
or was it like no bitcoin's this like
bigger thing and like of course there's
gonna be bad people who use all
Technologies including the internet cars
whatever and like so it's like a small
component of Bitcoin so I'll tell you a
story that kind of tells you what the
FBI at least my my perspective what the
FBI thought of crypto at the time okay
so we arrest Ross we find on the Silk
Road server and his server together it's
177 000 Bitcoins a pretty good chunk
even at that time it was about 200
million dollars yep I had it on a thumb
drive
um anything valuable goes up on to a a
special safe it's a walk-in safe in the
New York FBI
um that only opens on Tuesday Mornings
unless it's something valuable they'll
open it up to put it in I told them I
had 177 000 Bitcoins and all that
they're like the safe opens on Tuesday
what's Thursday I was like well I have
200 million dollars what am I gonna do
she goes you have two million dollars I
said no I have 177 000 Bitcoins so safe
opens on Tuesday I'll see you there and
so I had to walk around with a you like
physically had it yeah I was walking
around with it in my hand here it is I
can use all the Bitcoins I got to put it
someplace safe uh uh it was on me next
to my gun for a long time uh how did my
locked in my desk for a little while
because I didn't want to take it home
um I didn't know what to do with it I
mean I I went the channels and yeah but
the FBI just didn't know what it was it
was it was less about having an opinion
as to like uh this is not worthless it
was more of like we don't know what that
is yeah we don't know we don't
understand I mean this is you know right
after the big it was in the paper and
all that and I was like
you have to understand so
interesting because you had 177 000
Bitcoin which now is worth way more than
200 million
um there's two other people who had
access uh to bitcoin throughout all this
ended up taking it that were on the law
enforcement side they prior to the
takedown before before the whole thing
they had done an operation uh there was
still a secret service agent and a uh de
agent who had found an admin and uh
faked his death but he had access to the
backside of Silk Road at that time
they faked his death or he faked it they
faked his death they they faked they
killed him
um Ross asked so they pretended oh as
they're undercover undercover they
pretended they were Hitman and uh they
told Ross they would kill him and get
get his money back
um well really it was them that took the
money
got it
um and so that's the whole like there's
more complexity to than just a drug
Marketplace but at the same time it was
fake
yeah I mean that was the one of uh there
were six total where Ross had paid
someone to have people killed
um and you kind of see that Ross kept a
diary you kind of see that in the
evolution of of it
um where he changed for it was kind of
Heartache have him killed to the other
the last few ones and again it was there
was nobody he was being tricked
um was that uh you know oh I'll just
kill the roommates too with sort of the
the attitude towards it
I don't know how I feel yeah about the
like
somebody says something but it's a trick
like it's like intent versus not like I
I don't I don't know it's like a very
interesting weird dynamic because
usually it's like somebody commits a
crime they're like committed or they
don't right
um how does the government think about
it if we had not found Silk Road and
gone through and investigate all that
Ross would still would never have known
that he didn't kill six people or paid
to have six people killed so you know
what's the difference of an attitude if
I you know they have all these times
where they do Undercovers where wives
hire a hitman to kill their husband and
that's a really a cop
same charge I mean what would in your
mind what's the difference between that
yeah well I guess there's like a in one
way there's like a did it actually
happen or not he reached out and the
person said I would kill them and he
said okay here's the proof that I killed
them uh okay here's your money I sent
the wire I guess yeah yeah so it's not
the wire he said the Bitcoin
um is uh
okay
when you think about
um the other I'll call them law
enforcement cops or whatever Secret
Service and the D.A
was it kind of like
really guy like like almost like Hey
we're trying to do like good work here
and like this is going to be a
distraction or like what was the
reaction when you guys realized oh
there's like other sh there's like dirty
cops and they are involved in this we
weren't part of the investigations that
was the Baltimore investigation that
started along before we got involved in
Silk Road uh they were the ones with the
Sweat Equity
um was it Sweat Equity were they worried
about what we were going to find you
know they did they think they were just
operating you know anonymously and that
no one would ever track this down
um I don't know all these things came
into play only in hindsight
um so it's difficult to tell
and is that common like that there I
think that people
I think this is right if I'm wrong
people correct me
think people associate like I'll call it
just corruption in general like just
like kind of dirty cup stuff more with
local police officers like it's almost
like kind of petty stuff right it's like
oh they they arrest somebody they take
20 out of their pocket like again bad
should not happen whatever but like
we're talking about
like stealing a lot of money almost like
a white collar versus blue collar in
some way
um
now I don't know how people really feel
about it like I I feel like because of
politics and all sort of [ __ ] like
there's becoming more extremism whatever
but like in your experience you were a
local cop and he works at FBI like how
common is that stuff this is the only
experience I ever had into it really
yeah I never I never saw any of that
before yeah or since so so it's like
almost
is it fair to say like when it does
happen obviously gets a lot of attention
for you know proper reasons uh
but if it happens three times a year and
I'm making up a number and the public
hears about it that seems like a [ __ ]
ton but it's like out of you know
however many hundreds of thousands of
police officers or whatever
yeah I I I again I would have no idea
what the numbers are but I I didn't
experience I think everyone I've ever
experienced especially in the FBI
um was you know this is our mission
we're we're brothers we're gonna we're
gonna protect each other but we're not
gonna let commit crime yeah uh you know
no one's gonna go over that line no one
wants to risk their career and they
always have the FBI agents have a sense
of right and wrong I mean so you know
somebody's doing wrong yeah you know so
and I guess last question about the FBI
which um
I don't have yet like a fully formed
opinion about this because I think it's
like a moving Target but like the
politicalization of all law enforcement
seems to only be getting more severe
more obvious and like in some way law
enforcement becomes a pawn in the
political game of like one side's like
you know support the police the other
side's like you know defund the police
and then there's like almost like
sometimes switching yeah but everything
I mean politics is being grown crazy
these days yeah but I hear you the FBI
is in that lately yeah and then you know
to be fair I think to the CR the critics
of the FBI they're like oh they're like
uh implementing a political agenda and
then there's like other people who are
like no like they're trying to do their
job like
you worked at the organization like how
do you think about just like maybe what
they do to try to stay out of that stuff
and then also like is it just natural
for people that make up an organization
have political views and so like they
will get pulled in certain directions I
mean as a knuckle driver the guy doing
casework and all that we you know we
didn't see that like we didn't see the
politicalization I got involved in some
pretty high level cases that ended up
being in like the basement of the FBI
where uh you know I I come back and we
had this meeting with the top people the
not the director but everyone below them
um people from Justice and it was in the
basement and I saw kind of politics in
that so I can kind of see where it is
but at the the guys doing casework I I
don't nothing I mean I I was you know
there's guys you know they're different
political parties and all that but yeah
it didn't change their casework I mean
we all had the same Mission
um you know going for in the violation
we were going after I guess it's almost
kind of like uh there's plenty of people
who don't like the politics of Tesla
Amazon whatever you know CEOs Founders
leaders whatever ever but like the
Barista or the like software engineer
may not even have the same political
views or whatever like they're trying to
do their job to go home to their
families yeah that's all it is I mean
it's so I mean probably at the upper
management there's some sort of but but
we're not seeing it's not it's not
trickling down like I never I never
experienced personally or witnessed
someone to say oh you can't investigate
that or you have to go investigate that
uh I think that's actually a good way to
like
kind of focus because it's such like a
wishy-washy thing to talk about like
politics right but like I guess that's
really probably the single most like
measurable thing would be like are
investigations happening for political
reasons or investigations not happening
for political reasons it's like that's
almost where it gets executed right yeah
I mean again maybe my experiences are
limited maybe I'm naive but you know I'm
pretty pro-fbi and uh you know
it's been lately just seeing what's in
the news is is
I don't say embarrassing I'm not
embarrassed but it's it's strange for me
to stand up you know FBI you know uh you
know I'm like uh FBI a little bit so
yeah you know because it's hard to
believe what when I'm reading some of it
I don't think it's true but I don't know
I think a lot of veterans actually are
very similar to this where uh got a
[ __ ] Flag behind me right like I
think a lot of people are like I believe
in America I do also right but like you
can still be pro- something and also
disagree with certain things they do
like even if you're uh I don't know a
major league baseball player right and
you're like I love the New York Yankees
I don't think they should have done you
know X thing right I wish that we didn't
get swept right but like uh you can um
uh I think still be like macro supporter
but also disagree maybe on like the
individual details yeah you serve thank
you for your service I mean you you
probably didn't integrate with
everything that was going on but there
was times where I was like what the [ __ ]
are we doing here yeah but you still you
still went because that was your job you
did it and you served yeah it's uh it's
very similar um okay uh you don't work
at the FBI anymore uh you had this like
in some people's eyes like crazy life
some people was like holy [ __ ] it's all
entertaining other people are like I
would literally could not last one day
like tracking down people and like
that's just not what I enjoy doing or
whatever right so like there's a bunch
of reactions to kind of what you've done
previously
moving forward you now are very focused
on like cyber security stuff talk a
little bit about like what are the
threats that businesses and individuals
are facing and like the business that
you're building what are you guys
focused on actually doing yeah so
it's really difficult so we're kind of
three things we're focused on you know
we build uh solutions for people for
technology for people to you know that
that need
it's harder for me to talk around we're
building solutions for things that can
be solved we really like and that that r
d section of uh coming up with solutions
to do things uh is really kind of what
excites us
um because these are basically uh maybe
I can say it you can't but like these
are really significant cyber threats
that uh whether it's governments law
enforcement uh cyber security uh firms
what people just operate in this world
they have not yet figured out uh
repeatable software to be able to either
mitigate prevent whatever uh these
threats is that like generally oh yeah
we're very reactionary and so if we can
build some sort of solution that helps
you to react to something that's
happening bad in the world
um that's we enjoy doing that okay
that's one things we're focusing on
we're also focused on the cyber security
and we're also uh a lot of our business
now is crypto coming in with people that
have been victims of crypto attacks uh
people who have locked up their crypto
and need help getting access to it uh
talk about those two like so people who
have been victims somebody's hacked them
stolen stuff yeah you know we're seeing
it more and more we had a you know a
victim call us the other day for a
friend of a friend who you know sent us
over this information and the person had
looked up an exchange where their their
crypto was at they Googled it and they
found a phone number and they called
that phone number
um obviously they called the wrong phone
number uh the person explained to them
they could just give him access to their
computer they can help them yada yada
yada 400 000 in crypto was taken gone
you know and these are you know retirees
these are people you know this and this
is not the first phone call of the day
even yeah um and this is just happening
over and over and over again people are
getting involved in the technology they
don't really understand cyber security
is pretty easy if we just take humans
out of it yeah uh if we could just tell
people not to touch their computer it's
pretty easy to secure everything is that
most of the threat is it's like the
social engineering stuff it's the
low-hanging fruit it's the the easiest
way and and cyber criminals aren't going
to put in a bigger effort why put in a
bigger effort when there's so much in
the social engineering and easy to trick
people into doing things
um setting up fake websites and just
going through people's computers you
know if you get into crypto put it in
Cold Storage there's no reason you're
not moving it around too much so
especially retirees you know that's you
know and don't give someone access to
your computer I mean that's even easy
um and then people locking up their
crypto a lot of people you know forgot
about it we uh a journalist friend of
mine uh his wife had some crypto from
like 2014 forgot where it was forgot the
password we unlocked it for how do you
do that uh it's mostly Brute Force but
you use you know different sort of you
know techniques to how to was it
encrypted how you know can we eliminate
certain characters can we speed things
up
um you know it's like on an exchange or
and just like forgot my password no this
was like cold storage on our computer
yeah that file was sitting on a computer
and stuff like that or or you know we'll
work on you know if somebody has a
device uh and they can't get into it
we'll take a look at that
um so we're doing a lot of that work
it's good
um and really that's kind of really why
we formed nexo it was really kind of
it's the same team that did Silk Road um
same guys FBI guys
um and kind of the r d stuff try to
figure things out we were at
consultancies before this
um and you know Consulting doesn't want
billable hours we really want to are
focused on doing some r d and getting
back to kind of maybe helping people
um you know the retirees that lost all
their money if we can even just put them
in the right touch with the right people
you know it makes us feel a little bit
better what are the
um the biggest threats in your mind uh
from like a pure cyber security
standpoint is it like nation states is
it the like replacement organizations
for the ones that you guys took down
what do you see I mean if a nation
State's coming after you're not going to
stop it I mean there's so many exploits
let's look at NSO group Pegasus and I
honor that's a zero click
um vulnerability meaning that your phone
just has to be sitting on your
nightstand next to you and they had uh
your phone number they could then take
over your phone
what were they doing uh so there was it
was to pull in your contacts where you
were
um the you know allegedly that uh that
reporter was killed off of the
information taken from his phone
um but you know the entry point for that
is
uh Jamal khashoggi yeah uh was killed
because they were mad because the
information took off the phone or they
tracked it they tracked him they were
able to track him and find where he was
or maybe his wife's account again
um but the entry point for that's five
million dollars so
um we talked about Hector Montague
earlier he and I have a podcast now
hacker in the FED
um where we just that's right yeah so uh
we break that down and really the
takeaway is you know your phone is
vulnerable yes but if are you going to
be attacked by someone that has five
million dollars I'm probably not you
might be so it's something you might
want to think about because you know
chill I'm cool with everybody I'm cool
with everybody well your producer maybe
yeah I'm cool with everybody
so you know they have those things and
the media stirs those up you know that's
a big deal it's in the news the zero
click it sounds scary but you're
probably not going to be recognize that
yeah you're going to be victimized by
the phishing email phishing emails I
mean people clicking on things I I gotta
imagine that that's like the most
profitable business in the world so easy
you know you set up a simple page that
looks like you're logging into Gmail all
of a sudden now you type in your
username password they have it
um you know two-factor authentication
they're getting passed now
um we just had the SMS uh um all of the
uh SMS uh two factor that they were
basically getting the Sim swaps yeah
that seems to have died down quite a bit
because uh law enforcement seems to have
found a couple of the groups that were
like the big perpetrators yeah and it's
not it's again it's not that easy to to
grab somebody Sim and switch it out
there's much easier ways uh now they're
doing called MFA fatigue
um so that means they know you're using
your password because it was sold on the
dark web uh username passwords are all
over the dark web Millions every time uh
asks.fm was hacked into there's there's
300 million username passwords uh out
there connected to Twitter accounts that
was two months ago wait to see what next
18 months is Gonna Roll out of that
um but so now they have your username
and password and they just keep entering
in the site and you get a thing in your
phone it says approve approve approve
eventually you just wanted to stop so
you maybe you think it's your outlook on
your desktop computer that's asking for
signage and you just hit okay and that's
how now they're getting past two-factor
authentication uh mft MFA bombing or MFA
fatigue is what they're calling it now
so literally you know it's fake but you
just want it to stop so you might not
know it's fake because let's say you
have outlook on your computer and your
work requires you to log into two Factor
every 30 days maybe it's that you know
uh Dropbox their Engineers just got got
hit with this and these guys are in the
security industry they know not to click
on it they clicked on it you know it's
just over and over and over again so
things are moving towards Fido Fido
security so it'll be a token you'll
carry around you register all your
websites
um and what is the token better it's uh
it's it sets up a peer-to-peer
encryption
um so all the major players have gone to
it Google uh Microsoft everybody's uh
accepting it so you take the token in
you register your username your password
your communication and then every time
now you plug that in that same
connection is made so it's a it's a
passwordless entry system but you have
to carry a token with you
um lose that token you've lost access to
all your accounts so get two tokens make
sure you have a backup put that in a
safe place but you know passwords are
the least secure things and so we need
to start moving away from them yeah it
um
what do you do from like a security
standpoint obviously don't say anything
that would be too revealing but like
what would what do you do that
um
allows you to sleep at night where
you're like this is a good security
measure
I know the risks I know what the problem
is you know if you if you realize that
you're online you're putting yourself in
Risk uh you just realize what risk level
you're at I don't have a social media I
do that because I have kids and I really
don't want my you know my pictures with
my kids
um we've had our lives threatened
because of the Silk Road stuff so you
know I don't do pictures like that
um you know I I know some sort of
posture
do I I have an Alexa in my house I mean
that's a security risk there's an open
microphone listed in my house but it's
convenient it's convenient to order add
to the shopping list or if my wife's not
there she can add to it and that sort of
thing so convenience for his privacy um
you just have to wait and understand
your battle as old as time you'll never
have perfect but you know it's you know
and you also remember that you're
putting your data in the hands of all
these other people I'm putting my like I
put all my information to the FBI the
FBI got hacked into OPM the office of
personal management the Chinese hacked
into that and took all that information
there's nothing I can do I want to be an
FBI agent but all your information think
about all all the places where your
personal information is and realizing
that you know what's going on there some
of the trends you asked in the future so
we've kind of gone to you know away from
the password logins or we're now doing
biometric logins I don't think we're too
far away from like going to the grocery
store and it scans your face and you pay
for stuff
um can it be scary though if you lose
your personal information you can go get
another Social Security account number
and all that if you lose your biometric
information you can't replace that yeah
you can't get a new face yeah what the
hell are you going to do if they hack
into that and take your face from you
yeah um you know and all by the way they
don't want my Facebook I've got a
Facebook radio so that's why I started a
podcast that's why I go on podcast
um you know but so it's just we have to
stay out of these things so things like
the token I think that's going to be the
solver you mix the you know a token
based with your face very hard to steal
those two things yeah it feels like uh
it's the cat Mouse game yeah right and
and um
it's kind of your career really I think
represents it in terms of your you from
a law enforcement center trying to say
one step ahead now from the private
sector trying to stay one step ahead
yeah I mean we're not going to get the
like I said state-sponsored you know
those guys are putting you know they're
they're they're getting to uh if if
they're going after a company they're
putting they're higher in the janitor
the lowest paid guy to stick a thumb
drive in the back of your machine how
many people go to the company and look
on the back of their machine to see if
there's something in the USB port that's
a key logger that's log sending an
information home that's all it takes is
just put it in there and you'll never
find it
um you know so it either you can't stop
it yeah it's gonna happen yeah but be a
little bit more secure
I I think that's probably the best way
to do it is like I think a lot about
Security in terms of like you're gonna
make mistakes but like just mitigate
them like like or minimize the number of
mistakes right yeah minimize them but
also if it's a little bit inconvenient
for you it's really inconvenient for the
hacker and they're just going to go on
to the guy who is less inconvenient they
can take over their computer yeah why
spend time on it again story say
sponsorship if I'm coming after you
I'll get you you can't stop me there's
nothing you can do but if I'm just going
over somebody I just want somebody I'm
gonna go who's a little bit more
convenient to hack into yeah I think
that's a great place to end uh where can
we send people to find you on the
internet you can't find me uh I don't
put that's not a challenge I'm not
challenging hackers but uh the podcast
uh hacker in the FED download we put out
an episode every Thursday it's me and
Hector uh Hector montagueor Sabu uh
we're talking about uh the latest cyber
Stories We Tell old little sex stories
people write us emails to ask about FBI
questions or old uh old hacks uh that we
talk about so it's fun it's really just
time for me and Hector to sit down and
talk it's it's really therapeutic to be
honest with you it's the most
therapeutic thing I've ever done
um and then my company naxo.com just if
you need help with cyber security crypto
or anything like that reach out to us
awesome I really enjoy this conversation
I I uh think you've got a an amazing
array I think of experiences
um and I think I appreciate your ability
to say hey like this is the things that
happened but also like I get it there's
people who disagree with certain things
whatever and you know here's my views
yeah so thank you so much for coming and
we'll definitely do it again in the
future I appreciate you having me thanks
so much